The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Welcome back.
And today we will
continue doing some more
problems to do with
standing waves.
It's a very important topic,
so I thought it worthwhile
considering some different
kinds of problems.
So the first problem I
want to discuss with you
is the following.
Suppose you have two
equal-length strings,
each of length L, but
they are very different.
One is very massive.
The other one is very light.
And we tie the massive
one at one end.
It's connected to the
other one in the middle.
And the other one is tied here.
The whole system is taut.
And the question is, what
are two lowest normal modes
of vibrations?
Calculate the
frequencies of these
and sketch what they look like.
And I like this problem
because it's counter-intuitive.
You could take a few
seconds for yourself
and think whether you
could predict by guessing.
And I'm almost certain
your guess will be wrong.
Certainly, the first time
I tried to figure this out,
my intuition gave
me the wrong answer.
OK.
Now, again, it's idealized.
We'll assume that these strings
are ideal, lossless strings.
All the displacements
are very small.
So in the derivations of the
equations of motion, et cetera,
the usual sine
theta equals theta,
there is a constant
tension in this string T.
Because they are connected,
of course, like this,
the tension everywhere
must be the same.
And all we know is
that the density
per unit length of this
string, which I call mu sub H,
this is the heavy
string, is much bigger
than the density, the mass per
unit length, of the light one.
Now, the fact that
they don't give me
the values of these,
just say this,
basically is
telling me they want
almost a qualitative answer.
I cannot calculate it exactly if
I don't know these two numbers.
All right?
Now, the other thing we
are told is, of course,
a system like that can
oscillate in three dimensions.
It could oscillate up and
down, out of the board,
in, et cetera.
They're telling
us limit ourselves
to oscillations of the string
in the plane of the board.
OK?
So it's a 2D problem, not a
three-dimensional problem.
OK.
So how do we do this?
We immediately
recognize that when
you have a continuous line
of harmonic oscillators
in the continuum limit, and
that's what the string is,
the equation of motion
of the string is this.
This is the standard
wave equation.
It's the same equation
for the heavy string
and the light string.
And the only difference
is the phase velocity v,
which depends on the tension and
the mass density of the string.
So the heavy one we
will call v sub H,
and it's the square
root of T over mu H.
And the light one I call v sub
L, square root of T over mu L.
OK.
Since we know that mu H
is much bigger than mu L,
we immediately know that
vH is much less than vL.
That's the information we
have about those strings.
OK.
What else do we know
about this system?
I mean, we are now
in the usual process
of translating a
physical situation
into the mathematical
description of the system.
OK?
In this particular
idealized case,
this is almost a
mathematical description
up there, but still.
So this is the
equation of motion.
And the other thing we
know about the system
are the boundary conditions.
We know that at both ends, at
x equals 0 and at x equals 2L,
the string is tied down.
So that for all time, therefore,
the displacement will be 0,
y equals 0.
We know that at the boundary,
the strings are connected.
So at all times, y of
H must be equal to yL.
Otherwise, it would be broken.
So they're connected.
The displacement of the
string in the middle,
both the heavy one and the
light one, is the same,
and this is true at all times.
And the other thing
is that the slope
of the string on both
sides must be the same.
How do I know that?
Well, imagine the junction
to be some object.
Then that junction has 0 mass.
If it has 0 mass, you cannot
have a net vertical force
on that.
You cannot have a net
force on it, period.
Or because of Newton's laws,
force on the 0 mass object
will give it an
infinite acceleration.
It will just disappear there.
So at the junction, there
can be no net force.
The tension on the string
on both sides is the same.
And therefore, the slope of
the strings at all times,
on the left it must
equal the right.
So this is the complete
mathematical description.
And we are asked to,
with this information,
figure out, what are
the two lowest mode
frequencies and what
are their shapes?
OK?
So that's what now I will do.
OK.
Now, we know that
what we're interested
is in the normal mode.
If you have a normal system
oscillating in the normal mode,
you know that the
all parts oscillate
with the same frequency
and same phase.
That's the meaning of
being in the normal mode.
OK?
So we know that when this
system is oscillating
in the normal mode,
both sides of the string
will be oscillating with the
same omega, same frequency
and phase.
All right?
And also, on both sides
we have a string, a row,
a continuous row of
oscillators, and we
know what the normal mode
oscillations of such a system
is.
We've seen it over
and over again.
It is sinusoidal in fall.
So the general expression of
the displacement of the string,
whether it's on the left
side or on the right side,
will be the displacement
of it from equilibrium
is a sinusoidal function
in position multiplied
by a sinusoidal
function in time.
This function will be different
for the left and the right,
the spatial distribution.
This part will be the same.
Why would this be different
for the two sides?
Well, this equation
satisfies the wave equation.
It is the solution.
I am looking for
that wave equation.
If this is to satisfy
the wave equation,
you'll find that
omega/k, which you
can write like lambda times f
where lambda is the wavelength
and f is the frequency--
this is the angular
frequency on the
wave number-- has
to be equal to v.
Otherwise, this
would not satisfy
the wave equation.
OK?
And v is different
for the two strings.
All right?
We showed that.
We discussed it a second ago.
v, the phase velocity
for the heavy string,
is much smaller than
for the light one.
And therefore, if
omega is the same,
the k would be different
in the two cases.
OK.
Fine.
Now, using this, we know that
the wavelength is given by v/f.
Just I've copied it from there.
And since the frequency
on both sides is the same
but v is different,
I can immediately
conclude that the wavelength
of the part of the string which
is massive, the heavy one, over
the wavelength of the string
on the light side is
simply equal to vH over vL.
But we've been told that
the density of the heavy one
is much greater
than the light one.
Therefore, the
velocity, this one,
is much smaller than this one.
And therefore, we
immediately can
conclude that the wavelength
in the normal mode
oscillation of the
heavy one is much
shorter than of the light one.
All right.
So now if we were
given more information
exactly what these
quantities are, et cetera,
we could write the equations
of the string on both sides
and try to solve it.
And in the next
problem, I'll try
to do an example which is exact.
Here I'm treating the problem
of it more qualitatively.
And let's see what we can
figure out just from this fact
that the wavelength
of the massive one
is much smaller than
of the light one.
We are now looking for a
solution to this problem
where everything is moving with
the same phase and frequency.
All right?
And we are looking for
the lowest normal mode,
in other words, when
everything is moving
as slowly as possible subject
to the boundary conditions.
Now, moving slowly
means big wavelengths.
So what we have to try
to figure out-- here
is a sketch of this string.
This is the heavy one.
This is the light one.
And what we want, we want
to find, on each side,
this string is just
like any old string.
In the normal mode--
in a single mode,
will have a sinusoidal
function, all right,
of a single wavelength
on both sides.
So this must be a part of a
sine curve or a cosine curve.
So must this.
And we want to make it as
long wavelength as possible,
and we want to satisfy all
the boundary conditions.
So here it's located.
Here this one is located.
OK?
The one on the right, you want
to make as long a wavelength as
possible, and so this is
almost a straight line.
This is part of a
sine curve, but it's
almost a straight line.
This one is part
of a sine curve.
And at the boundary,
we must have
the two touch, so the
string is not broken,
and the slope to be the same.
So the answer is obvious.
The solution will be
something like a sine that
just turns around
near the top here.
And when the curvature
of this sine curve
is such that it points
towards this point,
then we have found the
lowest frequency solution.
All right?
This is approximate.
This will have very slight
curvature but approximate.
And so what we see,
when the wavelength
on the left-hand
side is basically
4 times this, which is 4L.
So this will be the
lowest normal mode
that we figured out without
solving any equations,
from just our knowledge
of the boundary conditions
and what normal mode solutions
are on the string like this.
All right?
Now, I can now,
knowing the wavelength,
I can calculate the frequency
this corresponds to because we
know that-- we've got it
here-- omega is simply
k times v. All right?
k is 2 pi over the wavelength.
So we have omega 1.
This is the lowest normal mode.
Angular frequency, 2 pi
over lambda 1 times vH.
We know what lambda 1 is.
We just argued ourselves to
show it's approximately 4L.
It's actually a little less
than 4L, but approximately 4L.
And so this is the lowest
normal mode frequency.
All right.
Now, what's the next normal?
They ask us for the two
lowest normal modes.
We repeat the argument.
We are now trying to figure
out-- each of these strings
now we would like to oscillate
with slightly higher frequency.
This, again, will be a
sine curve on both sides.
And again, we've got to
find a situation where
the curvature-- the sine
has shorter wavelength--
but the minimum shorter
that I can make it
so that I satisfy the
boundary conditions as before.
The strings must not break,
and the slope must be the same.
Well, if you play
around, you'll see
that the next lowest normal
mode will look like this.
The string goes like this.
All right?
And here, the massive
one is just curving.
And when its curvature
is such that it
points towards this origin,
where this is almost straight,
that will be the sketch
of the normal mode.
So that's what it
will look like.
That will be the next
lowest normal mode.
Now, what is the wavelength?
You can calculate
that from this length.
It's just a little
less than 4/3 L. OK?
And again, like before, since we
know the vH and the wavelength,
we can calculate the frequency.
So these are the two
normal mode frequencies.
And why did I say it's
counter-intuitive?
For you, maybe it is intuitive.
But I would have thought that
if you connect a heavy string
to a light one, it's
the light one that
would be wobbling up and
down and not the heavy one.
And in the reality, it's
the opposite that happens.
It's the little guy
that seems to be
deciding what the
big guy is doing.
And this is the
one which is-- also
this one-- all the time
is nearly straight.
The role of this one
is simply to keep
this end of the heavy
string tied down,
and it determines the
boundary condition here.
OK?
But it's an interesting
case to think about.
OK.
So that's the first
problem I wanted to do.
Now let's go to another one.
In some ways, it's similar
to the one we've done.
But just in order to show you
how general these discussions
are of these problems,
I'm taking a situation
where the displacement
from equilibrium
is not transverse to the
location of the oscillator.
I'm going to consider an
example of longitudinal waves.
Let me discuss the problem here.
This is the problem
we're going to consider.
We're going to consider a
solid rod attached to a wall.
So this is just a round rod.
It is connected to another rod.
Let's say take some case,
maybe a tungsten, a lead alloy,
a rod of tungsten
lead, which has
a certain Young's modulus y.
And Young's modulus,
let me remind you,
it is the extension
per unit length
if you apply to it a force,
certain force per unit area.
So it's extension
per unit length
divided by force
per unit length.
It tells you how,
under the system,
what strain you get
into the system.
This is analogous to
like, in a spring,
we talk of the constant
k for the spring.
Tells you how much
the spring [INAUDIBLE]
when you apply a force.
So the y will tell
you how much this
extends under a
force per unit area.
And I'm going to assume this rod
has a density rho, mass density
rho.
It's connected to another,
but this time much
lighter rod, a rod
which has three
lengths, 3L length, same area.
They are welded together
here, connected together,
glued together.
OK?
I've chosen two materials.
And if you look
in the books, you
can find different
materials having same y.
This is a carbon
fiber composite.
This is a tungsten-lead alloy.
And they both have the
same Young's modulus.
But this is much, much lighter.
The density of this is 1/9 of
the density of this material.
And I chose these-- I wanted
to come up with numbers where
one can solve the
problem completely.
In the previous problem, I
want to do this qualitatively
so I didn't have to pick
up numbers which gave you
a final mathematical description
which has an analytic solution.
OK.
So we have these two
rods connected like this.
This one is attached to a wall.
It cannot move.
And this is free.
I purposely wanted
a problem where
there are new
things coming in so
that you can see
how one tackles it.
OK.
As usual, there's
some assumption.
We're going to assume that
this is a lossless system,
while the rods are oscillating
that they're not losing energy,
that the oscillations
are small so
that we can do all the
usual approximations.
We'll make the assumption
that this radius is small
compared to this
length so that we
don't have to worry about
transverse oscillations
of the system.
We're only talking about
longitudinal oscillations.
So we're talking about
small oscillations
in the longitudinal direction.
And we are told that
for such a system--
and you could derive
it for yourselves--
that the phase velocity is
the square root of Young's
modulus divided by the density.
So it's different
for the two sides.
OK?
And the question
is, can we calculate
for this-- knowing
all these quantities,
these are now all
given quantities--
can we calculate what is
the angular frequency omega
1 of the first normal
mode as this oscillates?
The problem, in some ways, is
similar to the previous one.
But as I say, normally
we more often do things
like strings oscillating
because it's easier
to plot on the board the
displacement of the string,
which is in the y
direction, and the position
in the x direction.
Here we have the
displacement from equilibrium
at any point in
the same direction,
in the same as the position, and
that makes it harder to plot.
That's why one normally
doesn't take this example.
We tend to take
examples which are
easier to illustrate
on the board.
OK.
So let's now, as usual-- this
is the physical situation--
what does it correspond to
as a description in terms
of mathematics?
Well, let's define, at
any point x and time
t, the displacement
of the material
of the rod from the
position of equilibrium
by the Greek letter psi.
So it's psi at x of t
Now, this system is,
again, an ideal system
of a continuous distribution
of harmonic oscillators.
Each piece of mass oscillates
backwards and forwards
longitudinally.
That's the oscillator.
It's continuous, that is,
an oscillator at every x.
OK?
And each oscillator is
coupled to its neighbors.
So this is mathematically
exactly the same situation
as a string, where the
oscillators are there
oscillating up and down
instead of longitudinally.
So the equation of
motion of this system
will be, as always,
the wave equation.
This is the longitudinal
displacement,
how it's oscillating.
v is the phase velocity.
And we know that
the phase velocity
is the square root of
Young's modulus over density.
Since we know the
ratio of the densities,
and the y is the same
for both materials,
you know that the ratio of
the phase velocity in the two
materials, v2 over v1, will
be 3, the square root of 9.
OK?
And as always, we know that
omega/k is the phase velocity.
Otherwise, it wouldn't
satisfy this equation.
So we know that the k2/k1--
and I'm reminding you,
k is 2 pi over the
wavelength, right?
So k2/k1 is 1/3.
OK.
So this is the equations of
motion and the constants of it.
What are the
boundary conditions?
Well, they're slightly
different to the one
we've had of strings
attached at both ends.
We know that, in the
middle, the two rods
are attached to each other.
So the displacement
from equilibrium,
whether you're on the left
rod or on the right rod,
will be the same.
So the one on the
left, which I call
psi 1, at position
L [INAUDIBLE] t,
will be equal to
psi 2 at L of t.
So that's one
boundary condition.
Another boundary
condition is the one
analogous to when you
have two strings joined,
that the slope of the strings
must be the same on both sides
because the junction
has no mass.
Similarly here, the junction
between the two rods has no
mass, so there cannot be a
net force on that junction.
And since the y, the Young's
modulus, is the same,
the tension is the
same inside, then
the slope of d psi 1
dx at that junction
must equal to d
psi dx at the ther.
As I repeat, this is analogous
to a junction between two
strings when you're talking
about transverse oscillations
of strings.
The slope at the junction must
be the same on both sides,
unless there is a massive
object at that junction.
And we don't have such a thing.
If there was a heavy bead or
something at that junction,
this would no longer be true.
The other thing is, what
are the boundary conditions
of the ends?
On the left end, it's easier.
We said the left end is
attached to the wall,
therefore it cannot move.
OK?
Therefore, the displacement from
equilibrium of this left end
is equal to 0 at all times.
The right end is different.
It's free, and so
it's certainly not 0.
What do we know about that?
Well, at the end, the
rod ends, and there
is no mass or anything there.
So the end of the rod
is not pushing anything.
There's effective, it's pushing
a 0 mass at the end of it.
Therefore, there cannot
be a net force on that.
And so the rod cannot
be compressed at the end
or elongated because then it
would be exerting like a spring
attached to nothing with
exerted force on it,
which is not possible.
And so the rate of
change of psi 1 with x
of the displacement
from equilibrium
from x at the-- sorry,
I'm here, I'm here.
The slope of psi 2 with respect
to x at the end, which is-- I
am sorry.
This will be 4L.
This is my mistake.
This is 4L here.
OK.
At the end of the
rod, it has to be 0.
OK.
So this is now the
mathematical description.
And all we have to do is solve
the equation of motion subject
to these boundary
conditions and find out
what is the lowest frequency
that satisfies the boundary
conditions and
the wave equation.
OK?
And again, I have written
out the solution for you.
And let me go a
little faster now.
We now have experience.
We know that the wave equation
has standing wave solutions,
which are some amplitude times
a sinusoidal function in x
and a sinusoidal
function of time.
And now to save time, I am
going to inspect immediately
the boundary
conditions, and using,
in particular, these
boundary conditions,
the ones at x equals
0 and 4L for all time.
And I'm going to figure out
sinusoidal functions of x
and t, which satisfy
these boundary conditions.
Now, we know that we are
talking about standing waves.
So for both rods, the
angular frequency,
the [INAUDIBLE] oscillations
in time, will be the same.
So this part will be the same.
This part must satisfy
the boundary condition
at the extreme left
and right, which
forces me to write here
a sine k and here cosine
k2 of what happens
at the boundaries.
OK?
A good exercise
for you is slowly
think through the
boundary conditions
and the general solutions,
the normal mode solutions,
of the wave equation.
And you'll come
to the conclusion
that this describes the
standing waves in the two rods.
OK.
We know further that omega is
equal to k1 v1 in the left rod,
and equal to k2 v2
in the right rod.
This has to be the same
in both, as I said,
because we are in
the normal mode.
We're in a normal mode, where
the whole system is oscillating
with the same
frequency and phase.
OK.
Now, we will use the other bit
of information, the boundary
conditions at the junction,
which I've written here.
And from that, try to find a
solution that satisfies these
and see what is the angular
frequency of oscillation
for that.
So we can now write
at x equals L--
these are the two equations.
We'll take the displacement
of the rod on the left
and make it equal to the right
and the slope on the left
equal to the right.
On the left, this
is the equation.
On the right is that.
At that boundary to
make the two equal,
I get that A1 sine
k1 L at x equals
L is equal to A2 cosine
times this, all right, at x.
When we're talking
about x2 equals
L, L minus 4L is
minus 3, et cetera.
OK?
The cosine terms cancel
because the time part
cancels because they're
the same on both sides.
So this is the equation
we have to satisfy
so that the string
is not broken.
And I'm just
writing it like this
because we know that-- we
did that earlier-- that k2/k1
is 1/3.
And the cosine of a plus and
the minus angle is the same,
so I've just replaced
that with plus k1 L.
This is now looking
at the slopes
of the displacement
psi at that boundary.
So I differentiate
these with respect
to x, all right, this one and
that one, and equate them.
And I get this
equation, all right?
And so in order to satisfy
the boundary conditions
and the wave equation, I end
up with these two equations.
I've chosen things
such that these
can be solved analytically.
It's not hard.
You can do it for yourself.
You have two equations,
two unknowns.
The unknown is the
ratio of A2 to A1.
That's one unknown.
And the other unknown is k1.
You can solve these
equations trigonometrically
only because I've
chosen numbers of rho,
et cetera, which make
the answer come out.
And you end up that
you get k1 from it.
Knowing k1, you can
calculate omega.
And this is the
answer you will get.
I won't waste your time here.
You can do this
algebra for yourselves.
So here I've got
the final answer
because I had all the input.
If I had tried to do the
same with the string one,
if I chose some random ratio
of the density of the string
on both sides, everything
else would have been similar.
But here I would have ended up
with a transcendental equation,
in general, which I
cannot solve analytically.
And so if you take any
random case for yourself
and try to solve it, you would
find that, at this point,
you would be stuck.
You would be stuck with a
transcendental equation,
which, of course, you
could solve numerically
over the computer, et cetera.
OK.
So that's the end.
And now I'll come to the
third, yet another example
of standing waves, this
time in three dimensions.
So now we come to the third
standing wave problem.
And just for variety,
I decided to take one
in three dimensions.
So the problem is the following.
Suppose you have a room,
which is 2 meters in size
by 3 meters by 4.
What is the lowest
standing wave frequency
that you can get in such a room?
OK?
So it's basically a problem
to do with pressure waves,
because that's what sound
is, standing pressure
waves in three dimensions.
We are told that, in
this particular room,
what the density of the air is.
We're also told what the
bulk modulus, in other words,
how compressed the
air can get and what's
the resultant pressure--
what kind of compression
gives rise to air.
And we are asked to
calculate lowest normal mode
frequency of this system.
OK.
So how do we do this?
Not surprisingly,
you'll remember already
when we were talking about
one-dimensional system, way
the standing waves of strings
or on a rod, et cetera,
it's quite complex.
If you have three
dimensions, the situation
is getting more and
more complicated.
In this course,
we don't actually
derive the three-dimensional
wave equation.
But by analogy with
the one-dimensional one
and two-dimensional
one, we sort of indicate
what form you would
expect this to be.
And it actually is the case.
The three-dimensional
wave equation
for a scalar quantity
like pressure
that has no direction, all
right, is written here.
It's the d2p dt squared,
like for the one dimension,
is equal to v squared
times the gradient squared
of the pressure,
which, if I write it
in Cartesian coordinates,
it's written here.
Clearly, if I take a
three-dimensional system
but reduced two dimensions
with some small distances
so that, in essence, it's
a one-dimensional problem,
this gives you the wave
equation you would expect.
If I remove two of
these terms, what I
have is the wave equation
in one dimension.
OK.
In this equation, p
is the excess pressure
of the air above its
equilibrium Imagine the room.
Everything is at equilibrium.
The air is not moving.
The pressure is not
changing, et cetera.
There will be some pressure.
What we are
interested in is what
happens if we displace
that air from equilibrium,
change its pressure, and
let go, what will happen?
And so it's that excess
pressure we are interested.
That's the p.
And we are interested
to see if there is a way
to do that such that
the air in the room
everywhere, the
pressure, oscillates
with the same
frequency and phase.
If it does, then in
that room the air
will be in its normal mode,
oscillating in its normal mode.
One can show when one derives
this-- and I did not derive it,
of course-- is that
this v is the phase
velocity of propagation
of pressure waves in air,
the sound velocity, which is the
square root of the bulk modulus
divided by the density.
OK?
OK.
So the translation
of this problem
is this is the equation
of motion of the system.
And what are the
boundary conditions?
The boundary conditions are
that at the edges of the room,
at the walls, the
pressure does not
change perpendicular
to the wall.
So for example, the two walls,
at the end in the x direction,
at the end there, at one side
of the wall, the rate of change
of pressure with position and at
the other, it will not change.
Top and bottom, perpendicular,
it will not change this way.
It will not change.
Why is this the
boundary condition?
The reason for that is that
if you imagine at the wall,
the molecules cannot move,
right, because of the wall.
So therefore, you cannot
there, near the end,
increase the number
of molecules.
So perpendicular to
it, that the number
will be independent of the
position, which is dp dx,
is equal to 0.
OK?
And this is analogous to
the string situation, which
is attached to a
massless ring where
the slope is constant
at the boundary.
OK.
So with these
boundary conditions,
what are the solutions
of this equation?
OK?
To find the most general
solution of this equation,
it's obviously very,
very complicated.
There are infinite
possibilities.
But from my experience of
what happens in one dimension,
we can do a pretty
good, intelligent guess.
And what I've
written here, we can
guess that the solution
will look like that.
Why is it like this?
Well, first of all,
we want a solution
of this equation, which is a
normal mode, meaning everything
oscillating with the
same frequency and phase.
And so independent
of where you are,
the time dependence must
be the same for everything
or else it would not
be a normal mode.
So that's why that.
There is some amplitude,
so that's p maximum.
You would expect symmetry
between the three directions.
There's nothing
special between them.
And you want some
function here which
satisfies the
boundary conditions.
And what you will find is
that this, a cosine kx,
the slope of this with
respect to x gives you a sine.
And at x equals 0, you will
get the boundary condition
satisfied.
And we'll see in a
second what constraint
the boundary puts on
this at the other end.
For this to be a solution
of our wave equation,
we must satisfy this and that.
And so in some ways, you could
say, look, I've guessed it.
But then I'll use the uniqueness
there, say, OK, I've guessed it
or I knew it.
I guessed this was the solution.
I will now check, does it
satisfy everything I know,
the wave equation and
the boundary conditions?
And the answer is yes, it does.
And then I use the
uniqueness there
that says therefore that is the
only solution that satisfies
everything I know
about the situation.
OK.
Having done that, to get this
I used the boundary condition
as x equals 0.
But I want this slope also to
be 0 at the edges of the room.
And that gives me a constraint
on what each one of these cases
can be.
And you find that kx has to
be some constant pi over Lx,
where Lx is the length of
the room in the x direction,
so that the slope of this at
the edge of the room is 0.
Similarly for ky and kz.
And so you find that these
L's, m's, and n's, have to be
0, 1, 2, or 3.
They cannot all be 0.
If they are all 0,
then nothing goes on.
This means that k is
0, which makes omega 0.
It's a trivial, uninteresting
solution to our wave equation.
So at least one of these
has to be non-zero.
So which one will give
us the lowest frequency?
All right?
And so it will be the one
where the k, all right,
is as small as possible, which
means that the wavelength is
as long as possible.
OK?
So if we make the
L's and m, which
correspond to the room,
the 2 meter times 3 meters,
those to be 0, the only
direction we accept
is in the direction of
z, which is the longest
dimension of the room,
then that will give us
the longest wavelength and
therefore lowest frequency.
OK?
So k, the largest value
of the wavelength,
will be when kz is pi over 4m,
in other words, the wavelength
in that direction
being 8 meters.
And since we know that v is the
square root of the bulk modulus
divided by the density, I
could take the numbers that
are given, I get that the
phase velocity, or the velocity
of sound in this
room, is 342 meters.
The frequency, of course, is
equal to the phase velocity
over lambda.
Or the way I normally
remember, it's frequency times
lambda is the phase velocity.
All right?
And I found the longest
wavelength is 8 meters.
So from that, I get that
the lowest normal mode
will oscillate at
almost 43 hertz.
I'll just sketch for you here
what we've essentially-- we've
got this room,
and we are looking
for solutions which have
the longest wavelength.
See, in principle,
one could have
a wave like this
in this direction.
This, the slope, has
to be perpendicular
at the boundaries.
You could have,
in this direction,
for example, a wave like that.
And in this direction, you could
have [INAUDIBLE] or a higher
moment.
So it's hard for me to draw it.
But you can imagine
this pressure
changing in all directions.
But it has to be
represented, as I say,
by a sinusoidal function
whose slope at the boundaries
is always perpendicular
like this.
And the wave number
is, of course,
the sum of the wave
number of this squared
plus this squared
plus this squared,
taken the square root over.
The lowest frequency
will be when,
in this direction and this
direction, it's straight.
There's no change of pressure,
no change in this direction.
And the only direction
is in this direction,
and this is the
4-meter direction.
And that corresponds
to a wavelength
of 8 meter, which
I calculated there.
And so this will
behave in the same way
as a one-dimensional system.
Nothing changing
in two dimensions.
And only in one
dimension it's changing.
That will give you the
lowest normal mode.
And the other normal modes,
you can calculate the frequency
as you change the little
l, m, and n, play around.
Always remember, at least one
of them has to be non-zero.
And you can calculate all
the frequencies like this.
OK.
That's enough for today
on standing waves.
Thank you.